[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's time once again to go over the
latest free-to-play titles you may have
missed over the last few months
this series has been running for three
years now so should you not see a game
you want to play on this list
be sure to check out one of the others
to hopefully uncover a hidden gem or
revisit a game which has evolved since
the last time you played
this list is dedicated to the ps4 but
many of the titles here are available on
other platforms so hopefully something
for
everyone i'm going to tell you the bad
aspects of each game as well as the
great things okay so please throw me a
like to stop me from becoming a sellout
let's do this let's start with the
latest free-to-play game added to the
store
hyperscape yet another first person
battle royale game
so what does this one do the other ones
do not
here are a few things which are
impressive the first is the way weapons
upgrade
using a fusion system in which we are
able to pick up the same weapon multiple
times
each time this adapts the weapon's
functionality the mag size the range
the impact and finally on the last
fusion the damage numbers grow
this is a unique twist as in most vr
games we ignore floor loot after finding
our desired weapons
hype escape keeps us on the prowl for
longer the next area of note is the
traversal system in hyperscape
it's essentially a futuristic parkour
system in which
buildings can be scaled and fall damage
is missing
we all have double jumps to bring
verticality to the game
and the third point of note is the
abilities we acquire in game
known as hacks they could be something
like building a wall
or getting inside a ball we can become
invisible for a few seconds or
invulnerable for a few seconds and
there's many more too
after playing the game one thing i
believe you should know which is a
frustration
is the time to eliminate someone it's
ridiculously long
all the weapons just don't feel strong
it's unbelievably easy to run away from
a fight and parkour
somewhere different games began to feel
like hide and seek missions
which sucked the fun out of it for me
the game is receiving regular updates so
hopefully the weapons will feel more
balanced soon and less like water
pistols
and a little bit more deadly hyperscape
released yesterday if you're watching
the day i release this video
if you've tried it please let me know
your thoughts right now i had hoped to
talk to you about rogue company another
free-to-play game which was scheduled to
be released
right now but sadly that has been held
off for the time being and replaced with
an early adopter pack
which costs money it's a great game by
the way but let's talk about it
once it goes free to play the next game
is
perezo island probably the worst name of
a video game ever
right try this then have you heard of
animal crossing
well here is an attempt to recreate that
formula on ps4
you'll be set up on an island which has
a real time day night cycle
so if it's midnight in real life it's
midnight in the game too
the island will fill up with other
animals to create a village and your job
is to live alongside them
and craft items to upgrade your home and
theirs too
what genre would this be then a life
simulator i guess
we'll be planting and harvesting fruit
we'll be going fishing and just
generally
chilling out with your islanders i think
the main reason i'm including this game
on the list this time around is because
any money that's spent in the game will
go to real world
charities which may make me forgive how
clunky the game feels at present
ultimately if you don't have a nintendo
switch or you can't afford animal
crossing
try pareso island or not it's your life
next we have fantasy strike a street
fighter inspired one-on-one fighting
game
there's a ton of characters to choose
from and the game is super easy to play
but dedication is needed to master the
intricate timing of some skills
online fighting games usually fail due
to their poor net coding
so a great deal of time and effort has
gone into the netcode for fantasy strike
as it tries to be recognized alongside
juggernauts or fighters like tech and
street fighter and mortal kombat
the free-to-play update dropped in july
2020 which gives us access to all
fighters including two brand new
characters cyrus quince and general
onimaru
and the roster will continue to grow
there is a subscription model in place
to let the game make
money but the free version comes with
online casual ranked
practice and versus ai modes and there's
a whole bunch of cosmetic items too
there are some game modes locked away
for paying customers only
and that includes local battles so don't
expect to be playing this on a couch
with your best mate
here's the strangest brands i've ever
seen join forces
world of tanks and world wrestling
entertainment
i shizzle you not the war simulator
based around tank warfare has a
crossover with wwe summerslam
i know you've always wanted to take
stone cold steve austin into war
in a tank right well now you can becky
lynch is here too and the undertaker
and andre the giant and the sergeant
slaughter too
okay that one sort of makes sense my
main point here though is that world of
tanks continues to maintain a strong
user base
and with deals like this the future
looks good i tried my best to see if
john cena was here too
but i uh couldn't see anything here's
one i can't believe we've never added to
a free game list before
call of duty war zone if you haven't
heard of this you've been living under a
rock
a completely free-to-play battle royal
game which is great
the skill here is choosing the right
loadout and understanding lines of sight
as we are not able to build in this one
the loadouts can all be earned
completely free
but i have to say there is a hidden
pay-to-win element utilized throughout
this game
this is in two ways firstly the meta
weapons usually require egregious
unlocks
so for example the bruin lmg which is
the main choice of weapon right now
requires the player to eliminate three
players near smoke in one match
tough but not impossible right well this
must be done
15 times free-to-play players are at a
serious disadvantage
from those who own the game who can do
this in many other different modes
and to double down on this point if you
don't want to waste your time unlocking
the weapon to be
even on the battlefield you can pay for
it instead
it's it's very predatory but the game is
also very very good
and with game modes utilizing up to 200
players there is action constantly
i want to dislike this game but i can't
it's so good so grab a squad for this
one this is going to be here for years
to come
you either pay your way to stay equal or
you grind it out
that looks like that's the way it's
going to be the next game is rocket
league
so first let me state as i'm writing
this it is not available yet
but it is planned to drop any day
potentially without notice
over the summer months so instead of
waiting six months for the next episode
i'm going to bring it to your attention
now keep an eye on this one rocket
league is going free
it's been a paid experience for five
years the football car racing arcade
extravaganza
it was groundbreaking in its day and the
competitive scene surrounding the game
grew massively but now it's time to go
free to play
and you've likely already got this game
so here's something for you
you get more free stuff on the day the
game switches to free to play
more than 200 legacy items will be
available to you
the golden cosmos boost the day chiaro
wheels and the huntress player banner
it's pretty cool when a game switches to
free to play they still reward those who
have been there from the start
i like this anyway once i know exactly
when rocket league goes free to play
i'll update the description
below the next game is island saver a
game
made by a bank this is a game designed
to teach players about
saving and get this part there's even a
tax man who takes a proportion of your
hard-earned cash
this game is real life in a nutshell
but the gameplay itself is about saving
the world it's about cleaning up the
beaches and rescuing animals
in return for money and coins playing
longer you'll access other areas
and remember all the while you're
learning how the government takes your
money away
i wish i learned about that at school
the next game which is currently free to
play is a final fantasy 14 online
which is actually a trial version which
cuts off at level 35
well as of now this has been extended to
level 60
meaning you can play up to around 50
hours i'd say
for free including all content nothing
is blocked from you at all
if you don't know final fantasy 14 it's
an mmo rpg
a massively multiplayer online
role-playing game which began life
10 years ago as the name suggests this
is a fantasy world in which you choose a
server for your character to live in
it's a perpetual place which continues
to exist when you log off
each mission will ultimately lead to
fights and therefore you must choose a
class
a healer a tank or maybe dps
this kind of thing gets deep quick so
i'm gonna leave it there but if you want
to play final fantasy
for free for at least 50 hours here's
your opportunity
next we have the full release of don't
even think
it's another battle royale shooter but
this time with a werewolf twist
you'll be either a military badass
combatant like you used to in most of
the other games
attempting to be the last survivor or
you'll be aware being
tasked with taking everyone down before
they escape
it's a unique approach on br but i have
to admit it was in a pretty bad place
two months ago
so please let me know if you've tried
this since the full release
and should we all give it another go is
werewolf br
a good thing to play i'm not sure so
there we have it 10 more free to play
games on your ps4 should you need
something different to play
without spending any more cash i'm adam
from playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure like usual i'll keep you up to
date on all free to play games as they
release
see ya
you